[Música]
hablábamos de economía en directo
américa de france24 daniela blandón las
grandes petroleras del mundo alcanzaron
ganancias sin precedentes y la economía
mejor dicho los precios siguen subiendo
subiendo subiendo sube las ganancias y
era de esperarse que subieran las
ganancias en este trimestre con precios
del petróleo más altos y es que la
industria ha pasado durante mucho tiempo
por ciclos de auge y también de caída
pero debido a la guerra que rusia libra
contra ucrania y menos petróleo y menos
gas en el mercado y esto que hace raúl
sus precios precios eso hizo que las
multinacionales del petróleo nada harán
en ganancias y en ingresos en los tres
meses terminados en junio el presidente
yo bailé si usted lo recuerda ya lo
había anticipado hace unas semanas
exclamó exxonmobil ganó más dinero que
dios este año ahora vamos a ver si
regalar los regaños si señor vamos a ver
si es verdad las ganancias de la
británica
así como de las estadounidenses chevron
y exxonmobil efectivamente estuvieron
cerca de cuadro parce esto en el segundo
trimestre de este año frente al mismo
del año pasado mientras que la british
petroleum también británica las triplicó
eso es un comportamiento similar al que
tuvieron los ingresos también de estas
compañías danny y como lo estaba
diciendo al principio así como digamos
volaron las ganancias también hicieron
los precios de los combustibles pagamos
demasiado dinero por nuestras gasolinas
somos nosotros los que finalmente
pagamos porque los consumidores estamos
enfrentándonos a precios de la gasolina
históricamente elevados que sienten el
impacto no solamente en la estación en
la que tanque amos nuestros vehículos
raúl estamos viendo altísimos costos del
combustible inclusive en países que son
grandes productores de petróleo veamos
por ejemplo de datos de la agencia
especializada bloomberg que dicen que
están con corte a mayo de este año y que
en brasil una persona se gasta en
promedio una tercera parte del salario
mínimo mensual en llenar su tanque de 55
litros en méxico esa proporción es de
una cuarta parte es decir una cuarta
parte del salario mensual
en llenar un tanque de 55 litros en
argentina en chile y en colombia gastan
menos del 20% de ese mismo salario y en
eeuu dedicar en promedio un 6 por ciento
del sueldo mensual en abastecer el mismo
tanque hay un común denominador en todos
estos países raúl y es que con excepción
de chile producen grandes cantidades de
petróleo solo vamos a analizar en
nuestro segundo luego que con nuestro
invitado del día porque es bien
interesante así es danny pero mientras
tanto vamos a hablar de una preocupación
que hay en un país europeo por la falta
de turistas rusos estamos hablando de
chipre raúl no sé si lo conocen
honestamente no es mucho de chipre pero
se está recuperando tras dos años de
pandemia de kobe de
1950 con otras preocupaciones desde la
ausencia de turistas rusos ariana
villacorta nos tiene toda la historia
las fiestas con espuma en los bares de
la ciudad turística chipriota de haya
napa muestran que el número de turistas
se recupere en chipre tras dos años de
pandemia pero con la ausencia de una
nacionalidad clave los rusos esto debido
a las sanciones impuestas contra rusia
por su operación militar en ucrania se
captó fast move es un problema difícil
de afrontar pero de alguna manera
estamos tratando de hacerle frente hemos
limitado un poco los daños pero es
imposible reemplazar este enorme número
de clientes de latón en 2019 chipre
recibió casi 4 millones de turistas de
los cuales más de 780.000 eran rusos el
segundo grupo turístico más importante
por detrás de los británicos y el año
pasado a pesar de las restricciones para
frenar los contagios por kobe 19 uno de
cada cuatro turistas procedía de rusia y
pelas los rusos y ucranianos solían
representar el 25 30 por ciento de
nuestros huéspedes mientras que hoy el
número de turistas de estos dos países
es bajo
el ministerio de turismo estima que la
ausencia de esta zona unidades supondrá
una pérdida de 600 millones de euros
pero este no es el único reto al que se
miden la crisis energética también
aumenta la frustración entre los
hoteleros en la isla mediterránea éxodo
ahora mismo la electricidad se ha
convertido en el segundo coste más alto
después de los salarios lo que es
demasiado alto hay hoteles que me han
enviado su factura y se les ha pedido
que paguen sólo por un mes entre 100.000
y 150.000 euros
si bien faltan los turistas rusos y
ucranianos los maravillosos paisajes y
el sol veraniego permanecen en las
playas paradisíacas de chipre
bueno daniela y estamos viendo entonces
la falta de estos turistas en chipre los
turistas rusos que pues por el momento
evidentemente pues no están me imagino
viajando como tal por todo el problema
que hay por la invasión rusa ucrania
porque evidentemente me imagino ha
mermado también sus ganancias danny y
pues con todo este contexto le pregunto
que tenemos hoy entonces es como cifra
del día
le gusta la pizza amo la pizza pero con
mi alma incluso su fin de semana si vas
a comer pizza al final no sé por qué no
come y me dieron que nos otra vez bueno
pues que le den más ganas porque vamos a
hablar de la mayor cadena de pizzerías
del mundo se trata de domino's pizza que
redujo el 12% la utilidad en el segundo
trimestre de este año y la razón debido
a la guerra en ucrania la cadena de
pizzerías ya ha tenido que gastar más
dinero en ingredientes que van desde
cereales trigo hasta aceite lo que se
suma a los dolores de cabeza que ya
enfrentaba con los crecientes gastos de
también de mano de obra si es que hay
hasta escasez de conductores la buena
noticia para la empresa y mala para
nosotros es que los ingresos si subieron
32 por ciento pero no precisamente
porque vendiera más sino porque aumentó
sus precios en promedio en más del 15
por ciento en este primer como lo
estábamos hablando también dejar sino
que la empresa evidentemente no es que
vendió más sino que subió los presos los
precios para poder tener las ganancias
la rentabilidad que ellos necesitaban
exactamente es que la rentabilidad está
bajando en este caso de las pizzerías
porque recordemos que el trigo atrapado
en ucrania y en rusia pues está
afectando toda esta cadena de suministro
pues bueno dani yo la tengo que soltar
porque ya está alimentes listo para
hablar deportes pero les volvemos a
recordar en nuestra segunda hora vamos a
hablar de lo que pasa con todas estas
alzas de los precios del petróleo danny
muchísimas gracias ya nos vemos
saludamos alimentes